amen hey thanks for texting me to hang
out I really felt like we developed a
cool friendship and anyway it was just
nice to have that value yeah yeah yeah
look we've got some documents over at
entertainment 720 that seemed really
complicated and I thought maybe you
could take a look at them because nerd
stuff probably really excites you
because you're a nerd no of course yeah
no I'll just put on my Star Wars pajamas
and sit in my mom's basement pour over
some spreadsheets it sounds great yeah
what do you got something called Break
Even analysis tables oh break evens
those are really fun yeah sure I'll take
a look let's hit it right now I have
work and I thought
I had a friend all right it's almost too
easy
I can hear you I know you can Ben
100 whoa
unbelievable I cannot be stopped come on
now get some money come on April get in
your piece come on do it get some money
I don't care about that prize but I'm
gonna win because I want his happiness
to go away
together
[Music]
do you remember anything about a key or
April doing anything unusual that day
she did make a stop by the shoe shine
stand before we left because she wanted
to drop something off for Andy she had a
real bad crush on him
[Music]
babe you had a crush on me that's
embarrassing we're married still
hey Mark
um a little birdie told me that you have
won unpaid parking ticket that's funny
because a little birdie told me that
your adoptive mother was arrested for
marijuana possession
what you didn't know that huh
I didn't know I was adopted
what some fool just slammed me on Yelp I
took Ron's advice I very maturely and
straightforwardly left Anonymous
comments about Donna online
stop by to adopt a dog but the employee
Donna Meagle was nowhere to be found
thanks for nothing Donna Meagle boo with
five O's
we need to deal with what's bothering
you oh please come into my room see
you're angry at me and you're not
talking about it and I'm gonna beat you
up until you do because I'm mature
wait
stop it I grew up with five brothers and
we fought using the Dwyer method which
was yelling wrestling
crying followed by lots of hugs
and then more wrestling but the fun kind
and then crying when the fun kind of
wrestling got out of hand
um can you let me go that's how you tell
me what's wrong
[Music]
hey Mark
the shoe shot stand still doesn't have
that syphilis medication you were asking
about
and hey what a coincidence are you in
this office purely for business reasons
pleasure actually my boyfriend Mark
works here he's sitting right next to me
hey Andy what a surprise uh running into
you all day every day every single place
that we are likewise
well I guess I'll see you guys around
see ya oh uh also Mark again we don't
have those extra small condoms you
ordered
I called the factory it's going to take
a special order not just because of the
size but because of the weird shape as
well something they've never dealt with
before we'll talk
I want another
well there are none we're stretched
pretty thin right now then I want a
janitor they can do what you do right
yep nurses and janitors are totally
interchangeable except no one dresses up
like a janitor when they want to be
[__] I get the sense that maybe you're
angry at me for kissing Andy no I'm not
what are you talking about that's crazy
and that you think it might be fun to
take it out on me
please don't do that do I can't do
anything
I'm sick
[Music]
my blankets are on the floor
I thought you might like a fresh set of
pillows are you trying to smother me
help the [__] nurse is trying to
smother me to death with a pillow okay
never mind stay back [__] what about
your trust fund my parents had an
amended I don't get anything until I'm
50 which is a waste because I'm gonna be
a billionaire in Costa Rica by then
eating dolphins and hanging out with
Lady singers it's not a huge deal just
sit tight I'll take care of it you want
to come home with me don't you work at
Lady Foot Locker
oh my God the baby is Tom what this is
easily my favorite painting ever what
the hell Jerry look at my pot belly I
look like a pregnant baby and why am I
so scared all right we gotta take this
down now no this painting isn't going
anywhere Tom hello fellow lover of the
Arts
welcome to the painting
is that you
Love's hot
thank you
This Guy's in it too he's the little fat
baby
hey sorry about the whole mess crisis
has been averted so let's go talk to the
chief oh I already talked to him they'll
give us the hours we need no problem
great what a relief yeah
hey are you hungry I haven't eaten you
know
the great calzone place over in
idiotville oh really down on on terrible
idea Avenue okay that's weird because I
thought it was on beating a dead horse
Boulevard
calzones are pointless
they're just pizza that's harder to eat
no one likes them
good day sir Leslie you know I'm
just kidding let's go let's go oh
okay that was funny
anyone find any mistakes yeah actually
in here it says the Pawnee is great but
in reality it's terrible let Tom know we
haven't found anything
hey I'm thinking about getting a new
phone do you guys like your phones I've
never used a phone in my life
what about you Ron do you like your
phone
you know I think I'm just gonna
hang out here with you guys if that's
cool it's not
great
well I've made a little progress I'm up
to four seconds with April hey April I
was looking to get some new music and I
was wondering if you could recommend
anything the internet I really like your
haircut where'd you get it prison how's
your sister doing she has the shingles
who's your favorite character on Sex in
the City
Alf and nine seconds with Ron you're
stranded on a desert island what is the
one thing that you bring with you
silence
[Music]
you gotta help me man why it seems to be
going the usual amount of gross no this
is way different she's not married
anymore she had like five bottles of
alcohol she's calling me caramel he's
Gotta Throw Some cold water on the
situation start talking about nerd stuff
you know nerd culture is mainstream now
so when you use the word nerd
derogatorily means you're the one that's
out of the Zeitgeist yes that's perfect
just like that be incredibly boring
April you finalized a rental right shut
up man I told you never to talk to me
it's Champion oh my God I'm sorry bad
dog yes everything's fine with the
rental I think
I think things are starting to get a
little out of control here I agree you
betrayed me and you went behind my back
and now you need to pay
I need to I need to pay do I stutter oh
okay fair enough oh you know what you
might want to borrow this no no one
wants your dirty underwear but it's not
dirty underwear it's a white flag and
you may as well start waving it right
now unless you won't be waiting is your
decapitated head on a stick in front of
your weeping mother
good Lord I guess it would have to be
Channing Tatum's body Ryan Gosling's
face and Michael fassbender's sense of
humor what about you build your perfect
guy
um Yao Ming's torso
Napoleon's brain and the Hunchback of
Notre Dame's hunchback
do you like my nails
ah that sounds like the Newlywed Game
shut up Jerry what about my poem no one
wants you to read a poem okay Jerry
forget it Macklin you're too late I'm
sorry guys I I need my cheaters Jerry I
am making you my number two guy on the
new font project come on that's too
close let's make it my number three fair
enough Jerry you're number three there's
only two of us Rose Jerry hello
Jerry why are you calling me it take a
hike Jerry it's Larry now okay take a
hike Larry I gotta the pizza pizza time
it's a pizza time Larry everyone is
miserable and you are only making it
worse
are you in a cult can I join let's
sacrifice Larry now is not the time
Larry please leave
no no
damn it Mary sorry Larry Larry Larry
listen to me this is the worst thing
you've ever done damn it Terry Gary I
take everything back I hate you
I decided to finally retire this is
about people who are moving Gary not
everything is about you good point come
on Gary you're the mayor now has some
dignity
Pat listen to me if there's one thing
I've learned from myself
all right